um
let me ask about pesky little creatures
called pedestrians and cyclists
they seem so humans are a problem if we
can get rid of them i would
um but unfortunately they're all sort of
a source of joy and love and beauty so
let's keep them around they're also our
customers oh for your perspective yes
yes
for sure there's some money very good
um but
i don't even know where i was going oh
yes pedestrians and cyclists
uh i you know
they're a fascinating injection into the
system of
uncertainty of um
not like a game theoretic dance of what
to do
and also they have
perceptions of their own and they can
tweet about your product
so you don't want to run them over from
that perspective
i mean i don't know i'm joking a lot but
that i think
in seriousness like you know pedestrians
are a complicated um
uh computer vision problem a complicated
behavioral problem is there something
interesting you could say about
what you've learned from a machine
learning perspective
from also an autonomous vehicle and a
product perspective about
just interacting with the humans in this
world yeah
just you know to stay on record we care
deeply about the safety of pedestrians
you know even the ones that don't have
twitter accounts um
thank you all right but you know not me
but yes i i'm glad i'm glad somebody
does okay
uh but you know in all seriousness uh
safety
of vulnerable road users
pedestrians or cyclists is one of our
highest priorities
we do a tremendous amount of testing
and validation and put a very
significant emphasis
on you know the capabilities of our
systems that have to do with safety
around those unprotected vulnerable road
users
um you know cars just you know discussed
earlier in phoenix we have completely
empty cars completely driverless cars
driving in this very large area and you
know some kid
people use them to you know go to school
so they'll drive through school zones
all right so
uh kids uh are kind of the very special
class of those vulnerable user road
users right you want to be
you know super super safe and super
super cautious around those so we take
it very very very seriously
um and you know what does it take uh to
uh be good at it uh you know
an incredible amount of
performance across your whole stack
you know starts with hardware and again
you want to use
all sensing modalities available to you
imagine driving on a residential road
at night and kind of making a turn and
you don't have you know headlights
covering some part
of the space and like you know a kid
might run out and
you know lighters are amazing at that uh
they
see just as well in complete darkness as
they do during the day right so just
again it gives you that extra
uh uh you know
margin in terms of your capability and
performance and safety and quality
and in fact we often times uh in these
kinds of situations we have our system
detect something
in some cases even earlier than our
trained operators in the car might do
especially in conditions like you know
very dark nights
um so starts with sensing then you know
perception has to be incredibly good
and you have to be very very good at
kind of detecting
uh pedestrians uh in
all kinds of situations and all kinds of
environments including you know people
in weird poses uh people kind of running
uh around and you know being partially
occluded
so you know that that's stop number one
then you have to have in
very high accuracy and very low latency
in terms of your reactions
uh to you know what you know these uh
actors might do all right and we've put
a tremendous amount of engineering and
tremendous amount of validation in to
make sure our system performs uh
properly and you know oftentimes it does
require a very strong reaction
to do the same thing and we actually see
a lot of cases like that that's the the
long tail of really rare
you know really kind of crazy events uh
that contribute to the safety
around pedestrians like one one example
that comes to mind that we actually
happened uh in phoenix where we were uh
driving uh along and i think it was a 45
mile per hour road so in pretty high
speed traffic
and there was a sidewalk next to it and
there was a cyclist
on the sidewalk and as
uh we were in the right lane and right
next to the si uh so it was a multi-lane
road
uh so as we got close uh to the cyclist
on the sidewalk
uh it was a woman she tripped and fell
just fell right into the path of our
vehicle
all right um and our you know car
uh uh you know this was actually with a
test driver our test drivers uh
uh did exactly the right thing uh they
kind of reacted and came to stop it
requires both very strong
steering and uh you know strong
application of the brake uh and then we
simulated what our system would have
done
in that situation and it did exactly the
same thing it
and that that speaks to all of those
components of really good
state estimation and tracking and like
imagine you know a person
on a bike and they're falling over and
they're doing that right in front of you
right so you have to be real like things
are changing the appearance of that
whole
thing is changing right and the person
goes one way they're falling on the road
they're you know
being flat on the ground in front of you
you know the the bike goes flying the
other
direction like the two objects that used
to be one they're now you know
uh are splitting apart and the car has
to like detect all of that uh
like milliseconds matter and it doesn't
it's not good enough to just break you
have to like steer
and break and there's traffic around you
so like it all has to come together and
it was really great uh to see in this
case and other cases like that
that we're actually seeing in the wild
that our system is
you know performing exactly the way uh
that we would have liked and is able to
you know avoid uh collisions like this
such an exciting space for robotics like
in that split second
to make decisions of life and death i
don't know
the stakes are high in a sense but it's
also beautiful
that um so for somebody who loves
artificial intelligence the possibility
that an
ai system might be able to save a human
life
that's kind of exciting as a as a
problem like to wake up
it get it's terrifying probably from a
foreign engineer to wake up
and to think about but it's also
exciting because
it's like it's it's in your hands
you